so instead of carrying a small device
with you or having a computer screen in
front of you the computer or the device
will not anymore be a physical thing
that you look at it will be something
that can place information anywhere in
the world and so you can have screens
that move with you you can choose how
big or how many screens you want to
place around you as you work the
difference with now having to take out
your phone and if you want to see one of
those Holograms that we would share you
have to actively look for it if you have
these glasses on you will just be
walking around then if there's something
relevant for you it will just appear in
front of your eyes you're listening to
the Microsoft Research podcast a show
that brings you closer to the cutting
edge of technology research and the
scientists behind it I'm your host
Gretchen using
dr. mark polyphase is a professor of
computer science at ETH Zurich a partner
director of science for Microsoft and
the director of the new Microsoft mixed
reality and AI lab in Switzerland he's a
leader in the field of computer vision
research but it's hard to pin down
whether his work is really about the
future of computer vision or about a
vision of future computers arguably it's
both on today's podcast dr. Paul efface
brings us up to speed on the latest in
computer vision research including his
innovative work with Azure spatial
anchors tells us how devices like
connect and hololens may have cut their
teeth in gaming but turned out to be
game changers for both research and
industrial applications and explains how
while it's still early days now in the
future you're much more likely to put
your computer on your head than on your
desk or your lap that and much more on
this episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
mark pull a face welcome to the podcast
thank you so you are a few hats you're a
professor of computer science at ETH
Zurich a partner director of science for
Microsoft and now you're overseeing the
creation of a new Microsoft mixed
reality and AI lab in Switzerland so
it's pretty obvious what gets you up in
the morning tell us a little bit about
each of your roles and how you manage to
switch hats and work everything into a
day sure I've been a professor for quite
a while here in Switzerland and before
that in the US then almost three years
ago I joined Microsoft to work with Alex
kipman on mixed reality I spent two
years in Redmond working with a large
team of scientists and engineers on
moving computer vision technology on
Holland's forward for in particular we
worked on hololens - that was recently
announced I told Alex that I was gonna
do this for two years and then I wanted
to come back to Zurich back to being a
professor at ETH but after those two
years I realized that it was in a sense
very complementary so on one hand I'm
really excited about doing academic
basic research but I was also always
very interested in doing more Applied
Research and so I can partially do that
at ETH but of course there's no place to
have a bigger impact with that Applied
Research than Microsoft and so I
realized that I want to continue doing
that and so at that point I've discussed
with Alex what we could do what would
make sense and I realized that it was
something really interesting that could
be done which was to set up a lab here
in Zurich ETH being one of the top
schools to recruit talent for the type
of research that we need to do from
extremity at the same time from the side
of ETH
with my th had on great opportunity to
provide opportunities for students to
work with Microsoft to get access to
devices to resources that we would not
necessarily have at ETH a lot of
exciting projects to propose to the
students and so really essentially saw
that there was a real win-win between
you know what ETH can offer and what
Microsoft can offer
and so both of myself but actually for
everybody involved being able to kind of
find all those different elements and
bring them together and have something
really nice come out of that yeah so
yeah so there's synergies it is a lot of
work but there's also a lot of nice
synergies I want you to talk a little
bit about how collaboration happens
particularly with what you've got going
on Microsoft researchers collaborate
with ETH Zurich and EPFL researchers in
the Swiss joint Research Center or the
jrc tell us more about the Swiss GRC and
how it's helped you bridge the gap
between your eth zurich role in your
microsoft role yes so actually the GRC
is a program has been going on for about
10 years to stimulate collaboration
between microsoft eth and APL and I was
actually involved I think in 2008 or so
this was one of the first grants that I
got from Microsoft and so I worked on
the ETH side as a PI but in over the
years the scheme became much more
collaborative with PI's on both sides so
in the second generation of these
collaborative projects I had a project
with colleague here at Mulligan's who
was actually a former Microsoft
researcher and then collaborating with
researchers at Microsoft Research in
Cambridge and and in Redmond so that's
more like the project in the past now
currently we have also great synergies
with the GRC because having that
framework in place that facilitates
collaborative projects between the
different schools and Microsoft it means
that we can also in the area of mixed
reality where we want to foster more
collaboration also in the context of the
lab here this gives us a framework and a
way to facilitate extra collaborations
your primary area of research is
computer vision and you've specialized
in 3d computer vision so give us an
overview of your work in the field in
general just to set the stage for our
conversation today in broad strokes what
are the big questions you're asking and
the big problems you're trying to solve
so essentially computer vision is about
extracting information from image data
from images or video
this can be information like recognizing
things in the scene or it can also be
geometric information I'm much more
focused on extracting geometric
information from images
as an example this can be as you move
with a camera through scene being able
to recover the three-dimensional
surfaces in the scene a
three-dimensional reconstruction of the
scene this can also be recovering the
motion of the camera through the scenes
in which way the camera is moving
through that scene it can also be
finding back the location it can be
seeking out the calibration of the
camera it can be many different things
related to this geometry more and more
in recent years I've been also combining
that with at the same time also
extracting semantic information from the
scene and so having both geometry and
semantic information so that for example
when we do reconstruction we don't only
recollect surfaces but then we know that
part of the surface is a table and other
part of the surface is the floor for
example and a third part of the surface
could be the wall surfaces and so on and
so by doing both at the same time we can
achieve more and get better results for
the different tasks at once well let's
talk a little bit more deeply about the
different kinds of computer vision work
going on Microsoft has a lot of research
going on in computer vision and from a
variety of angles and when you and I
talked before you sort of differentiated
what you're doing with what some of the
other research areas in Microsoft are
doing so tell us how the work you're
doing is different yes so there's a lot
of research in computer vision we'll
look at an image and we'll extract
semantic information from that he will
recognize those objects or it will be
able to label different parts of the
scene this is an area that for a long
time or struggling to get really good
results but now with the advent of deep
learning there's been tremendous
progress in that area when you look at
what we are doing for mixed reality and
also what I'm doing here in my lab
extracting these geometric information
from images is not something that you
can ask simply tackle with these methods
that are now very popular in computer
vision of using deep learning a lot of
the kind of geometric computations are
instituted to be you know just easily
tackled with deep learning convolutional
neural networks or that type of approach
yes the classical methods that leverage
our strong understanding of geometry are
still you know very strongly needed to
get good quality results so for example
for
a device like hololens where it is
critically important to be able to know
exactly how the device moves through the
environment because it's actually what's
needed to give the impression of like a
hologram being starting in the
environment right so if I move my head I
need to somehow be able to fake the
impression that what I display on the
screen is static in the world as opposed
to being static on the screen to do that
I need to know very very precisely how
I'm moving my head for the environment
we do that by combination of inertial
sensors together with the camera image
data and so we analyze the image data to
compute how the headset is moving
through the world
that's why whole lines as a whole set of
cameras that observe the world it's
really to be able to track its position
all the time that's interesting because
you take for granted that when I move my
head like if I'm talking to you and I
move my head you're not going to move
with me that's right but with a device
it's good Pikul but of a different
experience unless you guys fix the
technical aspects of it so how are you
tackling that technically on hololens
you know these are techniques that
combine very much like we do with our
own eyes where we combine or visual
sensing together with our inner ear
which is more inner shell sensing
combining those two we can get a very
good impression of how we're moving
through space so we're actually doing
roughly the same for mixed reality it's
actually also very similar to what is
being used in robotics you can call it
visual inertial Adamo tree which is
determining your own motion from visual
inertial data or even if you go beyond
that people often call it slam this
stands for simultaneous localization and
mapping it means that while you are
localizing yourself your relative motion
in the environment you at the same time
building up a map of the environment so
that if you revisit it you can actually
recognize and realize that you have
already seen part of the scene and
correct your position or take that into
account to kind of continue to estimate
your position so this is used in
robotics in self-driving cars and also
very much in mixed reality and also form
in reality on phones the same techniques
are being used so this is a key element
in hololens
and so this device needs to be able to
track itself for the environment
so mark all argue that you're doing the
science behind what our future life with
computers will look like and a lot of it
has to do with how we experience reality
and you've alluded to that just recently
here currently I'll say we have
real-life reality I put that in air
quotes yes that in itself is you know
arguable and also what most people
referred to as virtual reality but we're
increasingly headed toward a world of
augmented and mixed reality where the
lines are a bit more blurred so tell us
about your vision for this world and I
don't want you to be sensational about
it I mean for real we're heading into a
different kind of paradigm here how does
it work and why do we need it even okay
so if you look at computers and mobile
phones for example there's a lot of
information that relates to the real
world that's available the first
generation of computing essentially was
you know it's a computer in your desk
and you might use mapping or other tools
to predetermine the route to a
particular place of interest but then
you still have to take that with you
that's what changed completely once we
went to mobile phones which essentially
is a mobile computer in your pocket so
you always have it with you that
computer actually knows about its
approximate position in space and so a
lot of things became possible like for
navigation for example or also
applications like uber or other
ride-sharing services and so on because
you have now information that is
spatially kind of with you in the real
world the next generation going beyond
that and where we go with miss reality
is really about having information not
only you know broadly contextually
placed in space but now actually going
to very precise positioning in space so
meaning that in general you can expect
not only to know this is roughly what
you have to go or look at your phone and
get instructions but you can imagine now
really to mix the digital information
that you currently see on the screen of
your phone and then the real world
information that you see in front of you
you can expect those to essentially be
merged to be mixed together in one
reality that's the reality in front of
you and so the info
nation that you need to do the task
which could be a navigation task or
could behavior technician a complicated
task to repair a machine needing to
carefully know which parts you have to
take out first and which you know button
you have to press etcetera all those
things cannot be communicated to you or
in you know in the future as we going
already now in a number of context with
mixed reality can be communicated to you
in a very intuitive way just by
overlaying the instructions on top of
the world visually so you can just see
things in front of you press this button
and it just shows you with an arrow like
the button or it shows you you know an
example of exactly what to do so it
makes it a lot simpler to process the
information and be able to tackle more
complicated tasks in that sense
[Music]
let's talk about microsoft's hololens
many people think of it as merely
another device or maybe a pair of
virtual reality glasses but it's
actually as you start to describe it the
world's first self-contained holographic
computer give us a brief history of
hololens to clear up any missed
perceptions we might have and then tell
us where and how hololens is primarily
being used today and then we'll start
talking about some of the specific work
you're doing so if you look at the first
generation hololens it was developed as
a development kit essentially for
Microsoft to learn about where this
could be used the initial concept was
already going all the way to the
long-term vision and so you can see that
on the first generation hololens it
wasn't clear if this was going to be
something for consumers or something for
industry or where exactly it would be
applied and it was but out there as you
know in a sense this magical device of
the future to see where it could be
useful to learn what type of tools and
what type of solutions could be
implemented on it so we learned a lot I
joined you know between hololens one and
alliance two I joined the team and it
became clear very quickly that we still
have a long ways to go in terms of form
factor in terms of a number of aspects
to get to something that makes sense to
use in your daily life all the time you
know as you currently use your cell
phone the device is still too bulky it's
too expensive for consumers etc so it's
too early for that
however it's not at all too early to use
device like Holland's one or now
obviously hololens - in settings where
you have tasks workers people that have
to do often complicated tasks in the
real world repair machines or it can
also be a surgeon for example who's also
a first-time worker person that's out in
the real world having to do a
complicated operation and essentially
needs access to information in a
seamless as possible way to help him do
that tasks
that's where hololens turned out to be
incredibly valuable because it's a full
computer that
you wear on your head it allows you to
place as much information as you want
around you you can in very natural ways
interface with it by speaking to it by
doing gestures so you can interact with
the device without even having to touch
anything you can use your hands to
actually do the task you supposed to do
in the real world and still get access
to all the information you need to help
you do that this magic of hololens is
that you have this full computer but you
can still use your hands to do the tasks
that you have to do hololens has some
really interesting applications but
right now it's mainly an enterprise tool
and is particularly useful for
researchers so tell us about this thing
called research mode in hololens
what is it and why is it such a powerful
tool especially for computer vision
researchers so hololens has all of these
sensors built in so you have this device
on your head that has sensors that look
at the world from the same viewpoint as
you are looking at the world we have
four cameras tracking the environment we
have this depth camera which can be used
in two different modes one for tracking
the hands and then a second mode which
is a smaller field of view but I'm more
powerful signal are two cents further
away which we use for doing our
construction of the 3d environment so
essentially we have all these different
imaging sensors moving with you through
the world so this is perfect for all
types of computer vision research
potential so for robotics research or
other applications you not have this
device that can collect data in real
time you can either process it on device
or over Wi-Fi send it to a more beefy
computer outside to do more expensive
computations if you want to or you can
just store the data to do experiments
but you can collect this very rich data
from all these different sensors to do
all types of computer vision experiments
which in particular if you thinking of
doing things like trying to understand
what the user is doing from a
first-person point of view you can
actually use these different sensor
streams to then develop computer vision
algorithms to understand what a person
is doing hmm
you just mentioned a more beefy computer
which raises the question what kind of a
computer or a processing unit shall we
said I've heard you refer to it as an HP
you are holographic
processing unit how big is the
processing unit what are we talking
about here well it's a small core
processor for Holland so you can very
much compare it to a state-of-the-art
cellphone in terms of the
general-purpose computing but then on
top of that because it needs to
continuously run all of these computer
vision tasks to be able to track itself
in the environment to be able to track
the hands to be able in online stew to
also track your eyes to know where
you're looking or to recognize you based
on our ease so all of these different
tasks most of them need to run all the
time yeah this means that this is four
hours at a time
it runs if you look at the cell phone
and you take your cell phone and you run
one of those fancy up menu at the apps
for example you will notice that after a
few minutes your phone is running
extremely hot because it's consuming a
lot of power to do all those
computations yeah and your battery is
draining very quickly we cannot afford a
non hololens so if you would just have
this general-purpose processor you could
run hololens for ten minutes and your
battery again hot exactly so this is
exactly why Microsoft had to develop its
own ASIC so its own chip which is the
HPU
which is the chip that's dedicated to do
all of this computer vision tasks and
other signal processing tasks very
efficiently at very low power and can
sustain that all along if you look at
hololens the whole system is you know
below 10 watts of power consumption if
you actually look carefully the whole
design of hololens is really done around
being able to consume as little power as
possible and be able to stay passively
cooled so that doesn't heat up your
forehead and so on okay how are you
doing that is it algorithms that help
you out and what is the technical
approach to solving those problems well
you have to be thinking in every
algorithm and everything you do you
really have to be very careful and
thinking right from the beginning how
much power is going to consume hmm it's
a lot of engineering effort to get to a
system that consumes that little power
and that amount of computer vision
processing all the time it means that
you can but some very efficient
processing units that I will suited to
do all these image processing operations
it means that some things that need to
happen hide the latency in the rendering
all of these tasks are hardware
accelerated with some dedicated hardware
in the HP you to make them run very
efficiently and it also means that you
have to be smart how you use the
algorithms and code things very
efficiently when you don't need all the
sensors all the time you don't use them
all the time it means that you really
try to add every point everywhere you
can you try to save energy and just do
what you need to do but not more
sounds like a teenager one of the
coolest things you're working on is
something you call spatial anchors talk
about the science behind spatial anchors
how do they work what are they actually
and what are some compelling virtual
content in the real-world use cases for
spatial anchors so spatial anchors are a
type of visual anchoring in the real
world so as you move your device to a
particular location and this can be
pover hololens or it can be a cell phone
that runs one of the AR Kotori our core
applications
you are essentially always generating a
little map of the environment and when
you want to place information in the
world you will attach it to this local
little map of the environment currently
with hololens you can place Holograms in
the world and on Owen's itself it will
be attached to a little map so that
hololens is continuously building a map
and so you can place it there then it
knows in the map where that hologram is
placed and then with hololens you can
see again that hologram when you walk by
the same place now what is your spatial
Angus is doing is allowing you to
extract a local little map and share
that with others in the clouds so that
they can also access your hologram if
you want to share to them so that means
that I can for example put on Hollande's
and place a hologram somewhere in the
world and then you could come by with
your mobile phone and use a architour
aircore to find back this hologram and
see it at the same place where I place
it in the world that means that now you
can start thinking of applications where
for example I can put virtual
breadcrumbs in the world and allow you
to navigate so these are for more
consumer-oriented applications but if
you look at applications like indoor
navigation or
you know if you think of applications in
an enterprise where there's all types of
machinery there's all types of sensors
there's things that we call digital
twins this means that you have for a
real machine in the real world you also
have somewhere digital representation of
it in your servers in the cloud that
information that is available in the
cloud you would like to be able to align
it also in the real world so that if you
walk around with your holographic
computer with your hololens on you can
actually see on top of the real world on
top of the real machine you can actually
also access in context all of the
information that relates to it now to do
that you need to know where you are and
where it is in the world and so that's
where technology like a geospatial
anchors can essentially allow you to
recover that now we are currently just
at the beginning of this technology
there's a lot of things we still have to
work out but the basics are there and
you can see online a lot of people are
giving it a try and are having fun with
it can you remove them of course you can
remove them and everybody can have their
own view of the world meaning a service
technician might want to see very
different things then you know like a
random person walking through a mall
this all becomes possible and different
people would have you know different
filters in a sense on all this virtual
information and you would have different
levels of access and privacy and all
these different things would come into
play to let you see the things that are
relevant to you so Microsoft Connect
let's talk about that for a second
because it has an interesting past some
of characterized it as a failure that
turned out to be a huge success
again I think a short history might be
in order and I'm not sure that you're
the historian if connect but I know
you've had a lot of connection with the
people who are connected to connect
let's say that yes tell us how connect
has impacted the work you're doing today
and how advances in cloud computing
cameras microphone arrays deep neural
nets etc have facilitated that so yeah
so if you look back Kinect was
introduced as a device for gaming for
the Xbox it had initially a great
success there but it was something more
for the casual gamer than for the
hardcore gamer but at the same time
they're also a little bit like with
research modes connect got opened up and
people could access this 3d sensing data
that Kinect was producing and this was
something that created quite a
revolution in robotics and in computer
vision where people suddenly had access
to a very cheap standardized very
powerful 3d camera and so this
stimulated all types of research both at
Microsoft Research and everywhere in
every vision and robotics lab around the
world people had connects what's
interesting is to see that then a lot of
this research that was developed on that
for example one of those is Kinect
fusion which consisted of taking single
Kinect depth images but as you move
through the environment having many of
those images
you know aligned to each other and
create a more global 3d reconstruction
of the environment so people developed
all kinds of very interesting techniques
many of those came back and enabled
Microsoft to develop much more
efficiently and already have an idea of
what was possible with the camera that
was going to be integrated in Hollands
what could all be put on it in terms of
algorithms and what was possible and so
on because they could just see what
happened to it Kinect in the research
world this was actually one of the big
reasons also there why I pushed for
having a research mode made available on
Hollins because I think there also we
can both provide a great tool to the
research community to work with in terms
of using Hollande's as a computer vision
device but at the same time also really
leverage that and benefit from it by
learning all the amazing things that are
possible that we might not think of
ourselves and this more or less
coincided with the time where we were
already with our second-generation
sensor in hololens which is an amazing
sensor that was built for hololens -
mm-hmm and so you know putting things
together it became clear that it made a
lot of sense to reuse that sensor and
put it in a third generation Kinect that
now is clearly not made for gaming but
is really directly targeted at
intelligent clouds type of scenarios
where you can have a device in the world
sensing with best-in-class
that sensor it can essentially do one
megapixel one million separate depth
measurements
thirty frames per second and all of that
below are what our consumptions were an
amazing sensor to combine that with a
color camera and a state-of-the-art
microphone array to bring back the
Kinect sensor package but in a much much
higher quality setting now yeah and
that's what does your Kinect is it seems
like we're heading for a huge paradigm
shift moving from a computer screen
world to a holographic world I mean
maybe that's an oversimplification but
I'm gonna go there and people have
suggested that Holograms have what it
takes to be the next Internet the next
big technical paradigm shift going
beyond individual devices and
manufacturers so what does the world
look like if you're wildly successful
well essentially it means that people
will wear device like hololens or
actually think more of a device like
normal glasses maybe a little bit beefy
glasses but much closer to today's
glasses than to today's hololens
that will enable them to see information
in a natural way on top of the world so
instead of carrying a small device with
you or having a computer screen in front
of you the computer or the device will
not anymore be a physical thing that you
look at it will be something that can
place information anywhere in the world
and so you can have screens that move
with you you can choose how big or how
many screens you want to place around
you as you work the difference with now
having to take out your phone and if you
want to see one of those Holograms that
we would share you have to actively look
for it if you have these glasses on you
will just be walking around and if
there's something relevant for you it
will just appear in front of your eyes
the information will just kind of always
be there in context just what you need
ideally so hopefully we can have some
good AI help with that and moderator and
just pick up the right things right and
show you what's helpful to you it will
be very different from where we are now
well that leads right into the time on
the podcast where I asked the what could
possibly go wrong
question I actually get kind of excited
about what I could do with a holographic
computer on my head but to be honest I'm
not sure I'm as excited about what other
people could do and I'll call them bad
actors or advertisers given the future
that you're literally inventing or
you're working on inventing does
anything keep you up at night about that
I certainly care a lot about the impact
on privacy for this so I think these
challenges but is also opportunities I
think it will be very important as we
will more and more have sensors
continuously move and sense the
environment be it on a hololens or on
your car in self-driving or just with
driver assistance systems did any other
systems or robots that will roam around
maybe your living room all of those will
have a lot of sensors so even more than
your cell phone in your pocket now you
we have sensors including cameras and so
on all the time sensing and so it's
really important to figure out how to
build systems that tackle the problems
that we want to tackle like being able
to know where you are in the world so
that you can see the holograms and the
things that are relevant to you but at
the same time not expose that in a way
that harms your privacy if you have a
map of the environments around you be
able to maybe represent those in a way
that allows you to do real localization
to be able to retrieve your Holograms
where they should be but doesn't allow
others to look at the inside of your
house or inside the spaces that they're
not supposed to look into so these are
actually active research topics that
we're working on today also at the same
time as we are pushing the technology
forward well and to other things pop
into my head like advertisers and
spatial anchors spam and transparency
concerns like if I'm wearing glasses
that look pretty natural how do I signal
or how do we signal to other people hey
we have a lot of information about you
that you might not be aware of I think
you're exactly right so those are all
really important issues and it's really
important to think about it as an
example the first generation Hollande's
was designed in a way that all of those
sensors that are needed to run
continuously to just be able to operate
hawaiians that all these data would not
be accessible to applications but just
be accessed
to the operating system and be isolated
in the HPU actually and not be exposed
on the general-purpose processor where
the applications live as a way to ensure
privacy by design in the hardware there
right so it's clear that these type of
things are very important it's often a
trade-off or at least let's say the easy
solution is a trade-off between privacy
and functionality yeah but I think
that's where we have to be smart and
where we have to start already doing
research in that space to work towards
the future that we can live in mark talk
a little bit about yourself your
background in your journey what got you
started in computer science how did you
end up doing computer vision research
and what was your path to Microsoft
not to mention all your other
destinations well you know so I come
from Belgium long ago when I was like 12
years old or so I wanted to get a game
computer and my father suggested it was
maybe a better idea to get our computer
on which I could program a bit and so
you know the result was that I kind of
thought it was pretty cool to program it
all and then I actually didn't study
computer science eventually I thought I
was gonna study computer science but I
ended up studying Electrical Engineering
which is close enough and one of the
last exams of my studies I had a
computer vision exam and professor there
asked if I was interested in maybe doing
a PhD with him and so that's how I got
started in computer vision and in
particular I picked a topic that you
know was really about 3d reconstruction
from images and have a lot of geometry
in there and from Belgium from Livan
University of Leuven I then moved to the
University of Carolina in Chapel Hill
where had a lot of colleagues doing
computer graphics for me the vision was
very complementary to that after a
number of years I got the opportunity to
move back to ETH Zurich which is you
know really one of the top schools
worldwide so I decided to move to
Switzerland and then in 2015 I guess I
got approached by Alex kipman and the
mixed reality team Orleans team at
Microsoft and I stated for a while but
then I realised that there was really an
opportunity to have a big impact you
know at some point even I had a
conversation with Satya that kind of
helped convince me to to come over and
you know help realize that
from Xfinity I hear he's very persuasive
and I was really impressed we were very
aligned from the vision and on where we
could go with this technology and what
we could do and so this was actually a
very good conversation so you packed up
and moved to Redmond that's right
and now you're back in Zurich that's
right actually before I decided to join
I told Alex I said I'm gonna come for
two years and you have to be okay with
that otherwise I'm not coming at all he
convinced me that he was okay with it
and so you know the end result is now
that eventually I didn't really want to
fully leave Microsoft I wanted actually
to both continue having in fact the
Microsoft but also felt that I could
really do something in between that you
know and have in some way the best of
both worlds in a sense it's to have jobs
turns out to be more than one job yeah
but I'm really excited about the
opportunity I got to do this well maybe
we can have a mark bulla face spatial
anchor here in Redmond and can work with
you there as we close what advice or
wisdom or even direction would you give
to any of our listeners who might be
interested in the work you're doing
where would you advise people to dig in
research wise in this world of the
holographic computer I think at this
point I really care about figuring out
how to get all of this amazing sensing
technology out in the world but at the
same time make sure that we have systems
that preserve privacy figuring out how
to marry those things I think is really
exciting and so that's one of the areas
I'm really working on and I hope a lot
of people are going to work on that mark
polo face great to have you with us from
Zurich today thanks for coming on the
podcast yeah thank you for having me
let's go
[Music]
to learn more about dr. mark polyphase
and Microsoft's vision for the future of
computer vision visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]